>> IT IS A RARITY, GIANNIS, TO
BE ABLE TO PLAY EIGHT YEARS WITH
A TEAMMATE, LET ALONE WIN A
CHAMPIONSHIP TOGETHER IN THOSE
EIGHT YEARS.
HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE WHAT
KHRIS MIDDLETON MEANS TO YOU?
>> KHRIS, WE DID IT, HUH?
YOU KNOW, I'M HAPPY.
I'M HAPPY, MAN.
THIS GUY DOESN'T REALLY KNOW HOW
MUCH HE PUSHED ME.
PUSHED ME EVERY DAY TO BE GREAT.
EVERY DAY TO BE GREAT, MAN, AND
I'M HAPPY I CAN STEP ON THE
FLOOR WITH THIS GUY AND PLAY
EVERY SINGLE DAY WITH THIS GUY,
AND THE OTHER GUYS BUT KHRIS IS
SPECIAL.
WE HAVE BEEN TOGETHER EIGHT
YEARS.
I WAS HAPPY I WAS ABLE TO DO IT
WITH HIM AND WITH MILWAUKEE.
WHAT DID COACH BUD SAY?
WE HAVE TO DO IT AGAIN.
>> I THINK THEY LIKE THAT.
GIANNIS, YOU'VE NEVER BEEN SHY
THAT FAMILY IS AT THE CORE OF
EVERYTHING YOU DO, AND NOW TWO
OF YOUR BROTHERS ARE NBA
CHAMPIONS.
>> WHOO!
I'M JUST HAPPY.
I'M HAPPY THAT, YOU KNOW, A LOT
OF PEOPLE IS MAKING JOKES LAST
YEAR.
WHEN KOSTAS WHON A CHAMPIONSHIP
WITH THE LAKERS.
IT WAS AWKWARD AT THE DINNER
TABLE, BECAUSE HE HAD A RING
BEFORE ME.
>> GIANNIS, CONGRATULATIONS.
KHRIS MIDDLETON, BRING THAT
TROPHY ON UP HERE.
KHRIS, IT SEEMED LIKE EVERY TIME
THE BUCKS NEEDED A BIG BUCKET IN
THIS SERIES, YOU WERE THE ONE TO
STEP UP AND DELIVER, WHAT DOES
IT MEAN TO YOU -- TO WIN A
CHAMPIONSHIP PLAYING THAT ROLE
FOR YOUR TEAMMATES?
>> IT MEANS EVERYTHING THAT THEY
HAVE TRUST IN ME.
EACH TIME PLAYING THE GAME
THEY'RE TELLING ME, GO GET THE
BALL, SHOOT IT, PASS IT.
WHATEVER YOU DO, JUST PLAY WITH
CONFIDENCE, BE AGGRESSIVE, AND
THAT GIVES ME ALL THE CONFIDENCE
IN THE WORLD IF MY TEAMMATES
HAVE IT.
>> SECOND-ROUND PICK.
SPENT SOME TIME IN THE G-LEAGUE,
TRADED.
HOW DO YOU STAY TRUE TO THE
BELIEF YOU HAD